lleven el maíz fue un presidente con
baja popularidad pero aún así tiene
seguidores que lloran su muerte al norte
de haití en cabo haitiano ciudad vecina
al pueblo natal de moix se celebró una
misa en su honor y los asistentes se
mostraron enfadados por su muerte
justicia para el presidente justicia
para mi presidente no voté por una
muerte como ésta murió como un criminal
como un asesino no voté para que muriera
así
cabo haitiano ha sido uno de los
epicentros de las protestas por la
muerte de maurice sus habitantes se
quejan de la pasividad policial en el
magnicidio una ira que ha llegado hasta
la capital las barricadas se extendieron
en puerto príncipe
vídeos para que la gente quiere gritar
todos están protestando porque el
presidente joven él está muerto por eso
todos están tristes por eso la gente
bloquea las calles
mientras tanto las autoridades de haití
preparan para este viernes el funeral
nacional del ex presidente que fue
asesinado el 7 de julio hasta este
momento hay 26 personas detenidas entre
ellos ex militares colombianos quienes
ingresaron a la casa oficial del
mandatario sin encontrar resistencia por
parte de la seguridad presidencial